ever wonder how they put trains together
of course you have
welcome to the cavernous siemens Train
Factory we're on sixty acres we have
about six hundred thousand-square-foot
under roof we put together complete
train sets with locomotives passenger
coaches the whole gamut is done right
here in Sacramento California the
process starts with piecing together the
coaches using 50,000 spot welds the roof
walls and floor are combined into what's
called the Cathedral because already the
scale is enormous next door technicians
are assembling the bogie that would be
the wheels and suspension now this part
is usually below the platform level so
it's invisible to us as passengers then
it's on to the paint shop it's just like
the paint shop for your car only on a
rather more significant scale but this
train isn't going anywhere without an
engine and this is it 16 cylinders 95
litres of displacement up to 44 hundred
horsepower or coupled up to an
alternator at the end the gorgeous
Goliath is craned into a waiting truck
this diesel hybrid produces electricity
to not only drive the motors for
locomotion but to provide power to the
passenger cars speaking of the cars
themselves are coming together next door
they have around 16 miles of wiring plus
picture windows high ceilings and comfy
seats these beauties are destined for
bright-line a new privately funded
service that will eventually connect
Miami to our lambu right line is the
country's first private-sector intercity
Express passenger rail service that
we're building to service the major
metropolitan areas of the state of
Laurens factory can make four passenger
coaches and four locomotives a month so
keep your eye out for the trains and
seven states around the u.s.